neural networks or deep learning I make
it sound like there's a Choose Your Own
Adventure element one or the other and
they are actually pretty much synonyms
deep learning refers to neural networks
with more than one layer or deep neural
networks and deep neural networks were
named
when there wasn't much computing power
to go around
and so we could barely dream of having
maybe two layers
stick with one but like maybe one day we
can achieve two
we shouldn't even hope about three today
they've all got many they've all got
more than two the real ones the
production ones they might have
thousands so they're all deep
all neural network stuff is deep
learning feel free to use this as
synonyms
what are neural networks layers upon
layers of mathematical transformations
these awesome complicated recipes but
they can do incredible things for you
where everything else is failed